cryptography is about mathematics it's
about science it's about politics it's
about privacy it's about human rights
it's about technology it's a whole mess
of different things and what you have is
something suddenly the development the
Telegraph you send messages around the
world instantaneously and encryptions
important because if you're going to
send messages you need to make sure
those messages aren't necessarily going
to be intercepted and stolen with with
radio communication you have that same
situation and when we get to the second
world war prior to the Second World War
the Germans realize that that radios
around you can send messages across
battlefields in an instant but if I can
send a radio message across a
battlefield in an instant then the other
side can also tap into those radio
channels so if we're going to have
high-tech radio communication we need to
have high-tech encryption pencil and
paper encryption isn't going to be good
enough and so the Germans as the other
country started working on it as well
but but it was abandoned in Scandinavia
and in America as well the Germans were
the only ones that really took it to its
logical conclusion and invented
something it looks a bit like a
typewriter a big cranky typewriter with
the keyboard and you type in your
message and out comes gibberish you send
the gibberish over the radio at the
other end somebody's got one of these
enigma machines when these clanky
typewriters they type in the gibberish
and the real original message comes out
and the complexity of the machine
guarantees you your privacy show us the
complexity of the machine right now I
believe that you have a machine an
actual Enigma machine from and is this
an actual this was actually used during
the Second World War this this machine
yeah this one I don't know a huge amount
about I've got one in London I'm very
fortunate have one which was used in the
Second World War and this one would have
been used in the Second World War
it's an Army machine no people in the
audience don't worry you're not gonna
have to Crane you're next we're actually
going to have a shot of it up here on
the UM on yeah on the stage for you so
you can see that a bit better hang
around this this nice wooden box it's
pretty heavy and when you open it up you
can see it does look just like a big
old-fashioned typewriter it's got a
keyboard here and the lamp board is
here so that's where the gibberish
appears is at the top and if we zoom in
a little bit up to about here if I type
in the letter P let's see what happens
the letter e lights up so P is encrypted
as an E but what's really clever about
the enigma is if I type in an E again a
P again a V lights up if I type in P
again a Y lights up so we have a random
letter generator the encryption doesn't
seem to follow any kind of pattern and
if you want a good form of encryption
that's what you need a kind of random
letter generator so where is this this
randomness coming from well we can open
up this machine here one thing we can
tell is it's probably built prewar
because this enamel plate was was only
used pre-war during the war they were
churning out these machines so quickly
they just had a peak paper stuck there
which would have come undone so here's
the lamp board here's the keyboard there
are 26 wires coming out of the keyboard
into the lamps but before they go into
the lamps they go round the side through
these three rotors here and I can take
these rotors out whoops
it's not my machine I'm very very what
about breaking it up so we can see here
it's got 26 contact so the 26 wires and
the keyboard going to the 26 contacts
and they come out these contacts here
and into those 26 contacts but in the
middle of this object
it's like spaghetti so an a will go in
at 12 o'clock but it might come out as
an F it will go in here as an F it might
come out as a G and so on so the
scrambled wiring inside these rotors is
what leads to the encryption but on its
own that's not enough scrambling is okay
scrambling is simple we can we can
scramble without needing a machine what
the Enigma allows us to do let me just
set it up in a certain way I've got it
set up here 21 16 there we go and 11 so
if I do that same process again if I hit
P three times I hit the P first time the
lamp lights up but also you're seeing
that that rotor moved if that rotor
moves
then the key that the wiring goes in at
a different Junction if it goes in a
different Junction it follows a
different electrical path if I type P
again you'll see the lamp light up
different lamp but also the rotor will
move there we go
and it's it's this dynamism for the
rotors that gives you the the
complicated encryption and when that
wrote has done a full revolution it
kicks the middle one when that's done a
full revolution it kicks the end one so
it's like a Milo meter on a car so
that's all very well in terms of
creating the the message what happens at
the other end how do you transfer how do
they decode it okay well first of all
you've got to have a machine so you can
have an enigma machine that'll help but
but but with all forms of encryption
this is called the algorithm this box of
tricks is the algorithm it does the
scrambling but you have to assume that
the other side know the algorithm they
know that they've got the Machine and
the the Brits the Allies we'd have had
one of these machines and so the real
security relies in how you set up the
machine so and your machine has to be
set up in the same way as mine so for
example I've got three rotors here those
three rotors could be swapped around
three rotors about six permutations this
rotor before I send the message can be
adjusted to one of 26 positions that can
be done to one of 26 positions that to
one of 26 positions 26 cubed from memory
I think is around 20,000 I could be
wrong multiplying it by the six
permutations gets us to about 100,000 I
can also change where this rotor kicks
that rotor that's another factor of 26
then I went up to like two and a half
million that one I can vary where that
one kicks out that's another 26 R up to
the hundreds of millions and and it's a
bit down here if we pan down a bit it's
what's called a plugboard here now all
this does is it pull it swaps letters so
if I plug a word Q with W when I type Q
the path follows w's path and when I
type W it follows Q's path now that
there are 20 20 cables here in 26 holes
and my memory is and it may be wrong but
I think they're a hundred million
million different ways to wire up that
simple bit of kit x the 100 million or
so we had before
and your machine has to be set up
exactly the same way as this so how do
we communicate about how do you tell me
what the configuration of my machine
needs to be in a way that doesn't suffer
the same you know lack of encryption
that we could have had just by
communicating freely in the first place
it's it's kind of crude what you have is
every month you have a bit of paper and
that bit of paper has the settings of
the machine and we might print we may be
in the North African Network Rommel in
his troops and everyone everyone in
Ronald's Network would have one of these
bits of paper and we wake up in the
morning we'd say right it's the third or
fourth of June and we'd set up our
machine according to that fourth of June
recipe and you've got the same piece of
paper then we can communicate but that
bit of paper has to be biked across the
desert yeah we you know that the guy
delivering it may be incompetent he may
be a double agent he may lose it and
this is known as a key distribution
problem and it's expensive
time-consuming and risky